hello everyone and welcome to spin more
om this website exists for a very
specific purpose there is a well of
information about po e online there's
tutorials there's workshop recaps
there's tech blogs people are pushing
the limits of what's possible and it's
amazing to see but what they're lacks is
an organization to all of that
information so spin more boy calm is a
site committed to curating the
information about spinning poi on the
internet so right here on the main page
we have sort of features video section
where you can see some of the coolest
point videos and then some feet down
here of different categories as new
posts come in they'll fill up these
spaces let's take me to a menu up at the
top other videos you have all the
different categories which will take you
to feed pages for these different
categories of poi videos and then we
have community we have a point community
encyclopedia where you can submit things
like glossary posts and we can try to
establish more conventions we have a
list of posts pinners known as people if
you see your name on this list then you
can write a bio for yourself someone
will click on your name and then it'll
come up with that bio and maybe link to
your YouTube account so you see your
name on the list go ahead and write a
bio for yourself and send it to me on
the submission form or you can add your
name to list by putting it on the
submission for London and we've even got
the blog where if you like you can write
a article without poi and then we'll
post it there got things like post about
point hardware we have a simulator for
learning poi this is an awesome tool
that's been designed by Glenn right
brilliant coder living over in the San
Francisco area you can use this to
simulate patterns to practice
and then we have a curriculum that's
intentionally designed for you to go
from any level of spinning up to any
difficulty that you're looking for so
all the way from uber beginner beginner
to intermediate advanced nuber advanced
this curriculum will take you through
the steps of learning point of course we
have a collection of links and contact
info if you have any criticism any
advice for the site whatsoever let me
know and we'll try to improve it over
time that is Raphael enjoy